he's the Chargers rookie defensive and
the former Buckeye Joey Bosa joining us
on the program so how's pro life
treating you Joey
treat me pretty well they're not too bad
cake Glen I what's the difference in
college life after a game and pro life
after a game
oh well color colors you gotta worry
about class on Monday but that's
probably the big difference but what is
table is different you know classes or
you have meetings right after you know
Sunday and then Monday you go in and you
review game film
I could I could do that all day have no
problems in football so I much much
prefer it now did you rent or buy I just
rent an apartment
I bought a better home down in South
Florida what's the what's the apartment
like in San Diego oh it's a pretty nice
bottom living downtown right now it's
the little spot looking over Petco Park
so do action there watching the games
but uh season's over now so it's been
all quiet
what's the fridge situation look like
the fridge yeah well I just recently
started doing with the service where
they deliver the ingredients and you
cook your own meals so it's pretty much
full of those meals that I haven't
gotten up and motivating myself to cook
can you walk around the streets and no
one bother you um yeah
san Diego's pretty laid-back most the
time but uh other than being at practice
until late in the afternoon I'm really
not wandering around the city too much
did you watch the Buckeyes in Wisconsin
game yeah of course
my family was actually here so we we
want the Buckeye bar out and out here
and there's a lot of fun to watch a
little too close
you don't have any Wisconsin teammates
that you would have watched the game
with Meldrum
yeah Melvin was out in Wisconsin
actually so I didn't want to make the
trip out there but my family was here so
it was nice to watch with them what was
that first Shack like it was awesome I'm
happy it came quick as a freshman in
college it took me I think six or seven
games to finally get my first pack and
to get in the first game once was pretty
rewarding how would you sum up your
rookie season so far short mr. Kamath
first few games but uh you know it's
it's uh it's been it's been tough we've
already faced a lot of adversity as a
team but I like my team a lot I like the
guys and I think we're gonna bounce back
strong and getting that one on Thursday
night need to go out for us then you got
the Falcons coming up in Atlanta this
weekend when you sack Matt Ryan could
you just say hey Dan Patrick said to say
hello is that asking too much no I don't
want you to taunt I don't want you
getting trouble within any it's just a
little bit nice yeah just just very
respectfully yeah the speed of the game
everybody talks about is it that much
different than playing in the big ten at
Ohio State I mean it's definitely
different you definitely notice
everybody's faster everybody's bigger
everybody's better because you know you
got the best of the best from around the
country but it's not anything too crazy
where it's like well you can't even
can't even imagine how fast it is it
takes a little adjusting but it's not
too crazy it's Joey Bosa the Chargers
rookie defensive end joining us Dan
Patrick show
could you see Urban Meyer
in his style coaching in the NFL um I
think wherever he goes he'll be
successful but I think he will thrive
more in college he's uh I mean he loves
coming into young kids lives and
changing it for the better so I think he
has a better opportunity of doing
something like that in college I feel
like kids respond respond to their coach
better in college and the pros II
sometimes get kids I mean in college see
not listening the coaches but like Urban
Meyer really has a big impact on kids
that are only 17 to 18 years old
Urban Meyer versus Jim Harbaugh who do
you have is that come on some serious
question right oh you got hardball in a
fight in a fight between those two and I
think they're amazed what you think I
think they I think they both just be a
lot of talk and I want to come down to
it they were naturally we have your
draft profile here can we can we read it
to you now we do this to all the rookies
can we do your draft profile all right
McLovin you want to do the draft profile
now these are just the negatives because
I'm sure there are a lot of positives
here for a Joey by the way he's known as
JJ Bosa to us unofficially yeah
no comparisons to anybody else Joey
you're just JJ Bose at us alright
McLovin read it - uh - JJ okay according
to nfl.com you are to contact oriented
in your rush and need to learn to
leverage yourself around the edge okay
forward lean can cause you to go flying
when defenders give you a shove okay
tape shows surprising like the place
strength when attacked on the edge what
the hell does this mean I yeah I don't
know really what uh what they're trying
to get across there here's one not as
twitchy as expected can be slow to pop
open huh bird twittering
bill will end up on the ground more
times than expected during a game lack
of strength when attacked on his edge
and do you read the did you read any of
this stuff it's pretty rough yeah
whether I'm sure there's some nice lives
in there any part
McLovin can you see something nice about
JJ Bosa here a good muscular definition
nice yeah
flexibility to go along with a confident
competitive attitude all right
solid upfield burst off the snap all
right blooming power in your hands what
wait are you serious that actually said
muscle definition yes do you feel better
about that Doug no that's so what people
are looking for and good football
players uh I don't know we I think it
was more for your Beach
Beach time that you have muscled up yeah
beach bod right there San Diego yeah
anything else that we can leave JJ with
so he's not really down down in the
dumps when he faces Atlanta yeah it's
weird nice hair I don't know why that's
in the draft you got to get a mullet you
got to go Clay Matthews and let it let
it flow
Joey yeah I train aware I'd bring it
back as a tribute to him that'd be
pretty good we'll see
hey congrats so far in the season have
fun against Atlanta as only you can and
thanks for joining us thank you thanks
for having me that's a JJ Bosa the
Chargers defensive end the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience